I was in what they call a follow-up car,
which the car immediately behind the presidential car,
but they're only about five feet between the two cars.
And this was when you heard a shot. We were traveling down main street,
large crowds in Dallas, friendly, enthusiastic. Again, we had to turn,
make a right-hand turn at the end of Maine and then a left on a street called
Elm street that put us right in front of a building called the Texas school book
depository.
And I was on the car immediately behind the presidential car was on the
left-hand side. On the running board.
I was scanning to my left and ahead head where there was an overpass.
And all of a sudden I heard this explosive noise over my right shoulder.
And so I immediately looked toward that noise,
but I only got as far as the back of the president's car that it
goes, I saw him react to something. So I'm grabbing his throat like this.
And then he went down to his left and I knew something is wrong.
So I jumped off the car,
ran as fast as I could to get up on top of the back of the president's car to
form a shield.
There are a barrier with my body so that no further damage could be done.
So you wanted to take the bullet if there was going to be any more gunfire? Yes,
that was my job. And so, uh, just before I got to the car,
there was a third shot, rang out.
The first shot hits the president just below the neck line to the right of the
spinal column and came out through the throat. Didn't hit anything hard,
just soft material. So it was survivable,
but the third shot that hit him. He only hit got hit twice,
but it was the third shot that hit him in the back of the head here.
But it exploded out here and it created
a situation where the brain matter blood bone fragments all came out of the
wound. It was quite destructive. And this was what you saw when you,
when you came to the car. I not only saw it,
but I felt it because blood came all over me and brain matter.
And over Mrs. Kennedy and the trunk.
I was up army headquarter,
about 30 of us had been recruited to,
to be trained as, um,
decoding assistant. We just got to the army headquarter,
which was 1.8 kilometer from hypo center.
About one mile,
I was on the second floor of the wooden building.
I saw the bluish white flush in the window,
and then my body was thrown up in the air.
I do remember the sensation of floating in the air because all
the buildings were flattened by the blast. And, uh,
obviously the building I was in was falling and my body was
together falling.
So, so you cannot, you can only from, from the, the destination itself,
what you remember is the flash and you yourself in the air.
That's right. No, no sound.
Well, people in the distance heard that roaring sound,
but I didn't. I was right in it.
And sometime later I found myself in a
total darkness and silence,
and I knew what was happening to me.
I was faced with death. I tried to move my body, but I couldn't.
Then I started hearing whispering voices of the
girls around me. Mother helped me. God, help me.
I remember those voices, belonging to certain people.
They still ring in my ears from time to time.
All of a sudden from behind the somebody shook my left
shoulder and with the male voice said,
don't give up kick, keep moving, keep kicking, keep pushing.
I'm trying to free you. And he helped me.
And he also suggested that I should crawl towards
the direction where the sound way what's coming through.
So I crawled up in the total darkness.
I began to see some moving object approaching me
for a while.
I couldn't say what those black things want,
but then I could tell there were injured human beings.
They didn't look like human beings.
I'll tell you their hair was standing up. Like,
why are the wires standing up?
And they were covered with blood and skins were scorched
blackened and, uh,
skiing and flesh were hanging from their bones.
And part of the bodies are missing.
And some people, I know this is gross,
but carrying their eyeballs in the eye in the hands.
And they were slowly shuffling from the center part of the
city,
but they collapsed onto the ground when they collapse their
stomach burst up.
And the intestine stretching out this kind of
situation I witnessed.
And that summer seven class mentioned that we were arrested,
trying to use the public library. That was a experience.
Later on, we saved, we own laboratory. Don't have to move it to you this,
and we'd be, we began the process. And that process led us to, uh,
we ended up going to Washington when Dr. King gave the speech that I have a
dream speech. And most of us were there. I had the, uh,
the honor of having been jailed and I became free of jails and death at
that time. And what most people don't realize the context of that speech,
the day he gave that speech from Texas across the floor left to
Maryland. We couldn't use a single public toilet in a state Capitol.
They gave this speech, we couldn't buy screaming holiday at Howard Johnson.
We couldn't buy [inaudible] counterfeited black and Latinos.
So I had to sit behind, not appeal debits to the American wheelchair basis.
We lived under the degradation of apartheid. So it was,
I didn't have to Google as it was. I was living it.
If you're going to now go back to 9th of October last year,
uh, you were on the school bus. Um, what,
what can you remember from that, that happened or what happened?
Well, I don't remember that incident and we will say you're lucky.
What's the last thing you remember?
I was going back home from school and on that day was my Pakistan studies
paper. We were having exams that we,
and I was really worried on that day.
It was a sad day because I usually try to get first positioned in my class
and to defeat all my friends in the class and be on the top.
And I was really worried about my exam paper. So when I was happy on the day,
quite happy because my favorite went very well on their day. And
Oh, we are going back home and, uh,
I could see the life was just like normal seeing those people on the road side.
And usually we have a lot of men on the road side, no women at all.
And if you see a woman, she would be wearing a burka.
And I thought that I sit in the school bus,
I was going back home,
but I didn't know that the journey was never going to end.
And I also didn't know that I'm never going to go back to my home
and the journey finished. And I woke up in a hospital in Birmingham.
Th there was, there was a man coming into the bus, right?
Yes. And he was asking for you.
So there were two men.
We will call them boys because they were in their twenties.
They were quite young.
And my friend told me the story and some other witnesses as well.
One of the boy, he stopped the school when,
and he was talking to the driver. My sister is behind it. I want to, uh,
I want to meet the principal of the school, making excuses,
just to keep him busy for a, for a while. And the other boy,
he came at the back of the bus and he
who is Malala, all the girls sitting in their school bus
and my school friends, they all looked at me. Some of them didn't,
but some of them did.
And they could not even imagine what was happening at that time,
because you are living a happy life.
And you're thinking about your exam and your homework and everything.
And then suddenly things change. So when he asked, who is Malala,
I could not answer him because he didn't give me time.
And when he recognized me, because I was not wearing, uh,
I was not covering my face. All the girls were covering their faces,
but my face he could see. So that's why, uh, he shot me in the bullet,
hit me right here on the left side of my forehead.
And it just went down through my neck and into the left shoulder.
And when I fell down, I fell in the lap of my best friend Winneba.
And when he told me that, when that boy asked,
who is Malala, you didn't say anything, neither did you cry,
nor did you scream. She said,
you just only forced my hand and you just you're like squeezing
it. And then you just, in the next few seconds, you just fell in my lap.
And then you're, my ear was bleeding.
And especially my year in this part was bleeding.
And the other two bullets hit my other friends, school,
friends, kindness, and Shazia.
And then suddenly those boys ran away.
Well, the war, Rob, the call of my family, you know,
it's rubbed the soul in my village.
The first time I witnessed war,
I thought the world was ending because I used to hear my mother telling me the
world is going to end someday.
And so in seeing people running different direction, you know,
you see animals even confused, big bombs, dropping ground check,
and like there's so much confusion.
And I got used to seeing people die. I still live in,
have the scars of the Wars. The first time it happened, even my leg got burned.
I fell, uh, a bike fell on me and I was on fire.
So the war reached the cough, my family.
So my aunt has died during the war, including my mom,
all my uncles later, when I get to hear more stories were claimed by the war.
And I think festered and
we'd keep running from one place to another.
And then we had to walk to Ethiopia. You had to walk to Ethiopia. That's a,
that's a very long walk, was a long cause month.
A lot of kids died on the way some died of starvation crossing the rivers.
Uh, there were beaten by hippopotamus, you know, hippopotamus don't eat,
but they're very territorial. So when you cross the river,
they able to smash somebody too.
And crocodiles were eating them some who don't know how to swim, get drown.
[Inaudible] the [inaudible].
As for most the thing I say [inaudible].
To call me [inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] uh, Auschwitz, uh, w w why did
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] in looked
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] they, they had a, bought a fabric and
[inaudible] standard
in disc ma.
And so store there some [inaudible] or
[inaudible] that [inaudible] [inaudible]
did real good. [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] some months
[inaudible] may last bill don't Congo.
[inaudible] being
the scuffle caffeinated coming from there.
They don't come from so
[inaudible]. So the first time.
Well, then to scan some
[inaudible] Dr. Mengele some, uh
[inaudible]
and all that you were in back in 72,
you were in Hanoi when the bombs fell really hard. Can you,
can you take us back there for a moment?
Well, when I went,
it was as a peace group to meet with a peace group
in Hanoi,
where they were no North Vietnamese communist party,
um, but wanted to talk, you know, just to talk. And we went over,
there was a, uh, minister and a Maoist kid, uh, is,
um, uh, you know,
a left-wing ex military and a four star
general with us. And we got there.
And all I can remember is the beginning.
There had not been any bombing there for half a year.
So nobody was expecting the sound of this siren went off at our
second night, second, big dinner, no welcoming us.
And the siren went off and I'm thinking of,
they must have these exercises all the time. And then we heard boom, boom,
and the distance. And, you know, for us, we didn't know what was happening,
really. The Vietnamese did, but they were stunned. Um,
but they got us down in bomb shelter. Um,
and I remember in the bomb shelter,
that's where I understood about my own
mortality. I mean,
I kind of was so frightened and a lot of times I'm not frightened.
I do this stuff. And if they come, you'll get very calm,
but you can't be calm in that atheist agnostics. Everybody's saying, dear God,
please don't let that bomb land on me. You know,
then afterwards you feel guilty because it fell on somebody else. I mean,
it's not a win-win situation. It was, it was pretty terrible.
I had a moment when I decided this passage,
this is not going to run to the bomb shelter.
So the next time the siren went off,
I was walking very slowly. There was explosion really, really near,
and everybody started running and I ran so fast.
I just lost all my brilliant self image I had. And I just up,
I couldn't get there fast,
other trampled people trying to get to the bomb shelter.
Th this,
this story is also famous for what then happened when you didn't have any food.
I mean, you had to take extreme measures. Yes.
When did you decide to do that?
It's um, I think our history, our stories,
a very interesting from that point of view for us,
it was only the, the only thing we could do.
And it's so strange to try and think I
would do it. I wouldn't do it. You don't looking at that TV show,
sitting on an Archer, reading and newspaper,
reading a book it's completely different. Over there. You change,
you change into the best of yourself or dependent on the point of view.
You descend to a worst of yourself as a human being,
but the pressures are completely,
and I haven't had any pressures or any problems in the last
38 years. Nothing that can compare to that. After 10 days,
we heard on a small transistor radio that the search had been abandoned.
We were left at 5,000 meters, no clothes, no food, no water,
no rescue. What do you do? You change? You're another person.
You turn yourself into a survival machine.
Is the decision to, to, to.
Eat human flesh.
And it was, it was a source of conflict in the group,
or no conflict did all of you eat or.
No conflict because, um,
if there's a fire in this studio here, we run to the door.
You willing run to where there is a wall over there on a limit situation like
that.
All the brain goes to a different wavelength and all the information that you
have, you are lost. You are abandoned to die. You are going to die.
Freezing looking at the eyes of your friends, sitting down here, you change.
You're a different human being.
I normally thought falling to a funnel and one comes out.
We have to survive. We have to eat.
The only things to eat are the dead boys of her friends. And it's so easy.
Once you're there,
it was harder to fight to get water. There's no water at 5,000 meters.
Th there was, there was an ambulance as well. Wasn't there?
Yeah. The, the mountains are,
are a very strong open-end, but there,
there are through what they are. There are mountains, you know,
men do not belong there. And two and a half weeks after the plane crash,
there was a huge avalanche because it snows, snows gets on top of the mountains,
then falls by gravity.
And we were right under the outlets and it varied
27 of us and it killed eight.
And then you were 16 left.
Yeah. Then three, four more that I, and then, uh, I had to get out of there.
I walked out with a friend, I say, walked out.
We tricked 70 kilometers, 10 days and a half.
We crossed the whole land, this wrong things on, on foot with street shoes,
with street shoes.
Um, I mean,
it experts say that this is almost humanly impossible to cross the
Andes mountains like that. Yeah. Um, why do you think you made it?
Because I wanted to see my father. Uh,
I knew that he was back at home, having lost his wife,
his daughter, his son, and we were a normal family,
but I knew he couldn't sleep. He couldn't work. He couldn't think,
and I was alive.
And the love for my father gave me the strength to go over those mountains.